jury selection continues today in the
trial of actor Bill Cosby five jurors
were selected yesterday Cosby was
charged in 2015 with aggravated indecent
assault against the Temple University
employee in 2004 he denies the charges
and says the encounter was consensual
case will be tried in Montgomery County
Pennsylvania that's outside Philadelphia
but a judge ruled that jury selection
would take place across the state in
Allegheny County near Pittsburgh 12
jurors and six alternates will be
selected from an especially large jury
pool of about 3000 CBS News legal
analyst Ricky Clement is here to bring
us up to date on that Ricky so what do
we know after the first day well the
first day I think went lightning-fast in
fact much faster than I expected what
the judge has done is he's had all of
the prospective jurors 3,000 and all
coming in in small panels of those
smaller panels of a hundred so what he
had them do was fill out a very lengthy
questionnaire before they came in that
the lawyers can study what happened
yesterday was the general questions went
out to the group and what they found was
a phenomenal amount of people who had
said that going to Allegheny from
Allegheny County to suburban
Philadelphia would be a hardship 67 of
the hundred what we also find is that
you have a huge number who have heard of
the case I mean phenomenal 80 or more
have heard about the case 14 of whom
said they could not possibly change
their opinion all I was really like yeah
ultimately 21 of them get interviewed
and what we have is the defense is at a
disadvantage here you have seven strikes
at which you can do for any reason no
reason and decide that those people
you're not going to use of your 12
jurors the defense has already used for
they've got only three devel yes that's
why you think there's going to be one of
the most significant parts of the whole
trial is the jury selection what about
race as a factor well you've got jury
selection which if the lawyers were able
to do it if the lawyers could actually
ask questions would be significant
indeed
I've spent years with some of the best
lawyers in the country including the
late race ordains
Jerry Spence teaching lawyers how to do
jury selection when lawyers get to try
to uncover bias here lawyers don't ask
questions and so what you're dealing
with with who's there and race you only
had three african-americans who were
questioned and all of them are excused
for cause defense at disadvantage beyond
race what do you think the defense
attorneys are looking for hidden jurors
and what are the prosecution looking for
in Georgia the defense would like older
people who might remember Bill Cosby as
America's dad and have that fond memory
people who might appreciate the quality
of celebrity the day obviously the
defense is looking for African American
jurors they're not many there the
defense and again we're dealing with
stereotypes here because that's all we
can do
the defense is looking for young people
who have a much different attitude about
what sexual assault really is and that's
very different from an older person I
want to go back to North question about
race because Bill Cosby himself has
raised it so far we were told yesterday
that they've selected five white jurors
they still have seven more to go is it
important that they have people of color
on this jury well I think to the defense
it's critically important the difficulty
they have Gailen picking a jury out in
Allegheny County out the Pittsburgh way
is that only ten percent of the
population is african-american I bet my
bottom dollar that he raises a motion
the defense about not getting a jury of
his peers now and for the integrity of
the outcome yeah Ricky cleamen thank you
so much